Lord McDonald says the Prime Minister
was informed about the complaint that
was upheld of inappropriate behavior
against their Minister does the minister
here accept Lord MacDonald is telling
the truth or is he telling us the Prime
Minister wasn't aware of it what
happened to the complaint Mr Speaker and
why was nothing done at the time a
minister of State at the foreign office
has a deeply sensitive role in National
Security was this issue even raised or
brought up in the vetting process and
was the Prime Minister informed and why
was this conduct not considered a breach
of the ministerial code why did the
Prime Minister allow him to stay in post
this goes to the heart of wider issues
here Mr Speaker and the public have had
enough
since the resignation of yet another of
the prime minister's ethics advisors
last month there has been an even bigger
ethical vacuum in Downing street with no
accountability in place how can the
minister come here today and say that
this simply just wouldn't happen again
the Prime Minister was personally
informed about these allegations and yet
he was either negligent or complicit
what message Mr Speaker does this send
about the standards of this government
and what they set what message does this
send to the British people facing a cost
of living crisis while their government
is paralyzed with Scandal when will this
Minister stop defending the indefensible
and say enough is enough
[Applause]
Mr Speaker the matter of what happened
with regards to the member for Tamworth
is now under investigation and it is
possible it is possible that a police
investigation may follow May so it is
clear that the subduity rule should
apply to individual cases both both
because of the interests of Justice to
uh to everyone concerned both to those
accused and those who are potential
victims so the subjuices rule should
apply very much to this debate but with
regards to the appointment that the
right honorable lady mentions to the
Wicks office in February appointments in
government are subject of course to
advice on matters of propriety not to
veto but they are subject to advice and
in addition the usual reshuffle
procedures were followed by government I
asked her has to accept that bearing in
mind the member in question had been
reappointed to government by a previous
prime minister in 2018 and then that he
had been appointed in 2019 as a foreign
office Minister and then crucially that
he was appointed for a third time in
February I doubt whether anyone could in
knowledge of those facts say that this
prime minister should have acted
otherwise than he did it is the morally
it is the morally fair thing to do in
any case
it is the morally fair thing to do in
any case to assess the situation based
on evidence
uh not unsubstantiated rumor it's
incumbent on all of us in this house as
it is in society generally to act fairly
if there is no evidence at the time if
there's no live complaint no ongoing
investigation surely it is not
unreasonable to consider making an
appointment now I have made some initial
inquiries subject to the this is subject
to further assessment but in the limited
amount of time available my my
understanding is as follows in October
2019 officials raised concerns with the
permanent secretary concerning the
member in question
uh the permanent secretary commissioned
work to establish facts uh that was
undertaken on his behalf by the cabinet
office
this exercise reported in due course to
the then permanent secretary who had
agreed its terms
the exercise established that while the
minister meant no harm what had occurred
caused a high level of discomfort
this is what the exercise established
the minister apologized
and uh those raising the concern
accepted the resolution
the Prime Minister was made aware of
this issue in late 2019
he was told that the permanent secretary
had taken the necessary action no issue
therefore arose about remaining as a
minister
and last week when fresh allegations
arose the Prime Minister did not
immediately recall the conversation in
late 2019 about this incident
as soon as he was reminded as soon as he
was reminded the number 10 press office
corrected their public lives so the
position is quite clear uh further
inquiries will be made but the position
is that the Prime Minister acted with
probity at all times
it is not appropriate whether in private
life or in public life to act on
unsubstantiated rumor